I don't think this is a purely
scientific problem when it comes to
Consciousness I think we have here an
ancient problem that philosophers have
traditionally referred to as the Mind
Body problem which is the difficulty of
how we fit together the physical world
and Consciousness how do they fit
together maybe it's the physical world
that's fundamental and Consciousness
arises from physical processes in the
brain but the psychist says well it
could be the other way around you can't
find out which of these views is right
with an experiment but what we can do is
try and look at the explanatory
aspirations of these two viewpoints and
which does better what's the explanatory
aspiration of the physicalist they try
to explain the emergence of
Consciousness in terms of physical brain
processes how well has that gone I would
argue it's gone absolutely nowhere